ROROMAIN LANSMANS
- - Quand on s'est vu, j'étais
vrvraiment dans l'optique
dede vouloir mourir. Et oui,
auaujourd'hui, j'ai des amis.
OuOui, j'ai mon petit chien qui
m'm'oblige à sortir tous
leles jours.
(a(aboiement)
C C'est complètement différent
auaujourd'hui que lorsqu'on s'et
rerencontrés. Oui.
- - Lors de notre première
rerencontre, Romain Lansmans étt
dédéterminé à mourir.
- - En 2014, j j'ai fait
unune première tentative
dede suicide. J'avais 20 ans.
J'J'ai été hospitalisé...
enen p psychiatrie. Je suis sori
dede l'hôpital, j'ai refait
unune tentative. J'y suis
reretourné.
- - Épuisé, il était arrivé
auau bout de son long parcours
dédépressif.
- - Je ne sais pas vraimenent
cocomment le formuler, mais
c'c'est l'angoisse... c'est...
c'c'est l'isolement, le retrait
papar rapport aux autres.
- - La psychiatrie,
leles médicaments,
leles psychothérapies
etet m même les électrochocs étt
imimpuissants à soigner son mal.
- - Si l'euthanasie m'est refus,
jeje pense que... enfin, non,
jeje ne pense pas, je suis sûr e
jeje passerai à l'acte...
susuicidaire. Oui.
A Aujourd'hui, je vais beaucoup
mimieux. C'est vrai qu'il y a eu
unun long parcours par rappoport
àà la demande d'euthanasie.
J'J'ai pu, suite à ça, rencontrr
unun médecin qui m'a relativemet
bibien aidé.
- - Peu de temps après notre
prpremière rencontre, Romain a
coconsulté le Dr Léon Constant
ququi se disait prêt à évaluer
sasa demande d'aide médicale
àà mourir.
DrDr LÉON CONSTANT,
mémédecin généraliste
- - Moi, je me suis positionné
enen disant : Bien, si tu es
enen confiance a avec moi, si tu
pepenses qu'on peut travailler
enensemble, je vais devenir
toton médecin traitant. Et on
veverra ensemble si l'euthanasie
esest la meilleure réponse.
JeJe n'ai pas dit oui, je n'ai s
didit non. J'ai dit : c'est
popossible,  mais on va
trtravailler.
- - Ça va. J'ai passé une semaie
cocorrecte. Toujours, quand mêm,
unun peu de stress.
- - Le docteur Constant est
coconnu pour avoir pratiqué
dede nombreuses euthanasies deps
l'l'entrée en vigueur de la loi,
ilil y a 20 ans. Il juge qu'il
s's'agit d'un soin médical tout
àà fait acceptable quand il
reremplit tous les critères prés
papar la loi. Et Romain répondat
àà plusieurs de ces critères.
MaMais le médecin a jugé que
soson cas était spécial. À cause
dede son type de maladie et
dede son jeune âge.
- - Je pense que le rapppport qe
nonous avons avec notre réalité
pspsychique et notre cerveau est
cocomplexe. Il évolue avec
lele temps et il est marqué
papar des traumatismes d'enfanc.
JeJe pense que dans le cas
dede Romain, c'est bien de cela
ququ'il s'agit. Et ça, ça peut
êêtre travaillé. Et avec
lele travail, on peut arriver
àà d'autres solutions.
♪♪ ♪ ♪
- - J'ai trouvé avec lui
unune écoute que je n'avais eue
nunulle part ailleurs.
- - Peu à peu, contre toute
atattente, Romain a repris goût
àà la vie.
- - Il y a eu une perte e de po.
UnUn gain de confiance en moi.
BiBien, je vis des choses, j'ai
momon appartement. Et je me dis
quque, bien, si la vie c c'est ,
bibien je suis peut être d'accod
dede continuer.
JAJACQUELINE HERREMANS,présiden,
AsAsso., Droit, , mourir, dignié
- - Je n ne pense pas qu'il y au
unun déclencheheur, un fait pré.
- - Jacqueline Herremans est
prprésidente de l'Association
bebelge pour le e Droit de mourr
dadans la dignité. Elle connaît
etet accompagne Romain dans
seses démarches depuis des anné.
C'C'est elle qui l'avait dirigé
vevers le docteur Constant.
- - Le fait que j'ai vu tout
dodoucement Romain se dégager
dede cela, de ne plus parler
dede suicide au cas où
onon l'entendrait pas par rappot
àà la demande d'euthanasie,
dede reprendre ses études. J'a'i
popoussé un ouf de soulagement,
bibien entendu.
- - Cette avocate et militanantt
memembre de la Commission
d'd'évaluation et de contrôle
dede la loi sur l'euthanasie
dedepuis son adoption en mai 20.
- - Au départ, on n'avait pas
nénécessairement penensé à des s
dede demande d'euthanasie pour
raraisons psychiatriques.
nonous pensions, au cancer.
OnOn pensait aux maladies
neneurodégénératatives, etc.
EtEt les demandes sont a arrivés
asassez rapidement en ce qui
coconcerne des patients atteints
dede dépression chronique pour
lelesquels il n'existait pas
dede possibilité de traitement.
- - La loi belge prévoit que
l'l'avis d'au moins deux médecis
esest nécessaire pour accorder
unune euthanasie. Et celui d'au
momoins un psychiatre, dans
leles cas de maladies d'ordre
pspsychique. Romain a rencontré
dedeux psychiatres qui lui ont
rerefusé l'accès à une morort
médidicalisée.
- - Moi, je considère que la loi
esest bien faite. Bien, je peux
meme prendre comme exemple.
FiFinalement... on m'a proposé
auautre chose, on a essayé autre
chchose, aujourd'hui,
çaça fonctionne.
- - Dans mon expérience, il y a
pepeut être une demande
d'd'euthanasie sur dix qui about
àà l'euthanasie. Parce que
leles situations de désespoir st
frfréquentes d dans la société.
PoPour moi, la loi est très bien
fafaite, mais c'est une loi qui
oboblige les médecins. C'est
unune loi qui nous honore, honoe
lele corps médical parce que ça
lului donne une responsabilité
énénorme.
- - Depuis le début de ses
mamalheurs, Romain souhaitait
susurtout que sa maladie soit
prprise au sérieux. L'euthanasie
n'n'était pas une fin en soi.
- - Moi, peut-être que si elle
avavait été obtenue, je l'aurais
papas mise en n place directeme,
mamais je savais, enfin,n, j'aus
pupu savoir que... si vraiment,
unun moment donné, c'était fini,
çaça n'allait plus,  il y avait
cecette possibilité-là, oui.
- - Bonjour.
- - Bonjour Romain.
- - Je pense qu'il a des bases
sosolides qui se mettent en plae
popour qu'il aille vers
unune construction d'une existee
ququi pourra être heureuse.
- - Romain Lansmans continue
àà voir son médecin au moins
unune fois par s semaine. Il ena
bebesoin. Sa s situation reste
frfragile.
- - Mais, le risque suicidaire
exexiste toujours. L'anxiété est
totoujours là. Donc, il y a une
didifficulté de vivre et qui
dodoit... qui doit continuer
àà être accompagnée.
- - On se reverrait dans 5 ans,
cece serait quoi votre situatio,
vovous pensez, idéalement?
- - En couple avec un enfant,
pepeut-être... Un travail qui me
plplaît, dans lequel je me
sesentirais épanoui. Avec
dedes contacts sociaux. Oui.
QuQuelque chose de... voilà,
dede positif, une petite famill,
unun travail, oui. Et voyage